movilizados por la defensa de sus
tierras ancestrales mientras el tribunal
supremo de brasil de retoma el caso del
llamado marco temporal un mecanismo
legal que nació en 2009 tras un
conflicto entre indígenas y agricultores
por el cual se estableció que un terreno
en el estado de roraima les pertenecía a
los pueblos originarios porque se
encontraban en el cuando se ratificó la
constitución en
1988 en este caso el fallo fue favorable
pero abrió la puerta a reclamar sobre
otros terrenos en los que los pueblos
indígenas no se encontraban en esa fecha
mi futuro en el futuro es luchar para
que las generaciones de mañana tengan un
futuro seguiré luchando por el pueblo
yanomami para que su tierra sea
protegido y respetada en repetidas
ocasiones el presidente es yahir
bolsonaro ha declarado que los pueblos
originarios constituyen menos del 1 por
ciento de los brasileños mientras que
viven en más del 13% del territorio del
país que debería ser explotado
elpresidente bolsonaro dice que nuestra
tierra es muy rica y quiero usar nuestra
tierra que ya está demarcada yo no
quiero esto los pueblos yanomami no
quieren que bolsonaro arruinen nuestras
tierras una vez más de materializarse en
ley el marco temporal sentaría un
precedente y provocaría retroceso de los
derechos de los pueblos originarios de
brasil muchas reservas quedarían
desamparadas frente a la minería y la
agroindustria con consecuencias
catastróficas para la amazonía